conference and to my knowledge no one
has even mentioned the pandemic so what
I'm wondering is first of all do you
have any concerns about all of these
crowds gathering regardless of the
purpose and regardless of the passion in
terms of public health I'd love it also
if one of your public health experts
who's on this call could answer as well
how much are you concerned that there
will be a rise in Kovac cases as a
result of all of these crowds and why
have you not made public health
statements over the last couple of days
reminding people about social distancing
yeah
Andrew excellent questions we've been
talking about this I don't think we have
our public health folks on now but they
can certainly speak to it later Andrew
this is I have to say and I want to just
express this openly to everyone just a
few days ago what we were entirely
focused on all of us was one of the
greatest challenges this city has ever
ever faced this pandemic this you know
painful horrible crisis taking the lives
of so many New Yorkers when I was out in
central Brooklyn yesterday maybe I had
you know 15 20 conversations with just
everyday people on the street
overwhelmingly people were talking about
their concerns about their health about
their kids about the fact they were
running out of money or they had not
gotten checks from the federal
government some people of course raised
concerns about criminal justice but most
people are dealing with this crisis
they're scared they're scared for their
health they're scared for their family's
health they're worried that they don't
know where things are going with this
coronavirus that hasn't stopped Andrew I
think the honest truth is we are dealing
with right in the middle of that another
absolutely unforeseen moment that's vast
in its scale that it you know there had
not been the coronavirus now this last
few days would stand out in American
history as a painful profound moment and
you're seeing it happening literally in
cities big and small
looks like entirely all over the country
so I think we've got to almost you know
exact opposite realities if you will
that are colliding at the same time now
the disparities pervade both let me
hasten to say the disparities the racism
that is inherent in what happened with
the pandemic is also inherent in all the
concerns running through the policing
debate we've got to address them across
the board we've been trying to for years
we have to do a lot more but to your
central point it's very hard to say to
people you know when there's such pain
there's such anger that if you say don't
come out because of the pandemic and I
think this is something we grapple with
all the time we don't want people to
hear that as we are not hearing your
concerns or your concerns are not valid
or we don't have to change things and
it's a very tough balance and again this
is happening on a such a painful intense
national scale this is not like before
this we had small protests and I kept
saying whatever you're left right or
Center I wish people would stay home not
protest do it virtually but this moment
is the outpouring of such pain and
frustration years and years decades
generations of pain and frustration
outpouring this is a different reality
we've had to adapt to it we've had to
try and understand it and address it and
I am very worried about the health
impact to the core of your question I
would urge everyone to think about this
and I do think for those who have made
their presence felt made their voices
heard the safest thing for this point is
to stay home obviously because we don't
want people in close proximity to each
other we don't want people out there
where they might catch this disease or
spread this disease and I think more and
more people have to realize there is a
danger that it will cause some real
impact on the resurgence of this disease
we don't have the facts yet Andrew and
these things are happening outdoors
that's better thank God and if people
were gathering together indoors but
there's a real danger here
there's no question there's a danger
this could intensify the spread of the
corona virus just at a point when we
were starting to beat it back profoundly
so I want to beseech everyone to think
about that I would certainly urge
everyone look she's made your point it's
time to stay home if you do go out
please try and anywhere you can to
observe social distancing and keep those
face coverings on but Andrew in
conclusion this is just a horribly
complex situation it just is we've never
dealt with anything like this this
combination of features and we're all
trying to find our way to the best
solutions that's the honest truth
the next is Marcia from CBS mr. mayor
good morning how you doing I'm all right
Marcia how you doing so I have a couple
of questions first of all at there at
times it seemed because of the violent
protestors have joined that the police
have been overwhelmed and I'm wondering
if there's a so-called war plan going
forward for how the police are going to
deal with both the peaceful protesters
and those who would seek to do violence
or to loot or to engage the police in in
a violent way and my second question has
to do with the briefing that John Miller
gave yesterday about these protesters
since the NYPD did have intelligence
about the fact that they wanted to loot
and they were ordered according to their
encrypted messages to target high-volume
stores what fancy stores chain stores in
wealthy communities why weren't the
police able to get ahead of that and
stop it I'll start and I'll turn to
Commissioner the way you opened the
question Marcia I know you were you were
speaking sincerely but I would never use
the words you just used there we have a
peace plan we have a plan to keep the
peace and even with all the tensions of
the last few days again thank God no
loss of life thank God we have not seen
a lot of serious injuries
we had some situations that could have
been very very bad that were averted
in large measure because police
leadership showed restraint and saw
situations and dealt with them before
they got worse and we've got things that
weren't done well and we have to fix but
overwhelmingly the plan has been to keep
the peace to respect the peaceful
protestors to deal with those who are
aiming to do violence and that was
working it was not perfect by any
stretch and the fact that a lot of these
violent protesters in particular break
off and go all over in different groups
makes it really challenging for the
police now that's not new in the world
Marsha we've been seeing that kind of
violent protest that kind of tactic for
years around the world we hadn't seen it
as much in this city again some of this
is from the city and some of this is
from outside but that puts a real strain
on the NYPD trying to chase all sorts of
groups and trying to be present in so
many areas simultaneously that said it
was working and working in many ways
very well until about nine o'clock last
night and then we saw something we
hadn't seen as much and that now needs
to be defended against in a new and
different way and that's what what
happened today there was a lot of
presence out and we're going to make
sure that presence is in the right
places seeing what we now are seeing
from this violent few but we from the
peaceful protesters we saw people trying
to just get their message out and not
attacking property not attacking people
so this is a day-to-day hour-to-hour
thing and we're going to constantly make
those adjustments commissioner yeah
Marcia thank you for the question I mean
when you talk about intelligence and
deployment and how they come together I
think the mayor touched on what we face
at times trying to be that even keel in
respecting the right to protest in
dealing with cowards if you will that
are hijacking a cause and look to do ill
will to New Yorkers whether it's
property damage whether it's bigger
don't think of the New Yorkers that are
calling for help and now have to wait
longer I mean it just has so many
impacts by some of these whether it's
barricades of fires or looting
that is taking place so the officers
have been very nimble I think when you
look at what happened last night we're
still tallying up the arrests they were
certainly deployed in the right place
and engaging I expect there to be close
to probably 400 or more arrests just
from last night Marsha just regarding
looting and similar types of activities
and we need the rest of the criminal
justice system now to step in as well
and we need a deterrent and we need
larger consequences
we need the Manhattan DA's office we
need the Brooklyn DA's office to do
their job and make sure that people have
the right to protest freely but there is
a line and when you take bricks whether
it's throwing it at police officers I
can't say enough to thank the Eastern
District for prosecuting those cowards
that threw a Molotov cocktail at our
offices but all of these I think we
separate minor actions and being
flexible and understanding the
environment we're in and allowing people
to protest we know that there's going to
be some minor arrests made we are able
to deal with that and I think that comes
with the territory
and everyone understands that on both
sides what we do not have patience for
is violence lighting fight you're
putting people's lives at risk and
that's what we need the prosecutors to
step in and make people understand that
it's unacceptable and there are
consequences okay last question for
today goes to Henry from pix I just
wanted to zero in on these issues of
outsiders a little bit more I'm
wondering why mr. mayor and missioner
were shying away from being more
specific I know one out of seven were
outside of State according to mr. Miller
the other day but you know what is
what's the ethnic background where the
political background we're hearing white
supremacists in other states so so with
all that intelligence why can't you be
more specific about what's going on here
I mean we will get you Henry this is
going to be day to day gathering
information and I've said to the
Commissioner John Miller keep putting it
out to the media as you get facts keep
putting it out I'll be plain what we're
seeing certainly from the people coming
out of town
primarily white people and certainly
from some of the young people that we
have seen who are not from neighborhoods
and go into neighborhoods and do
violence they happen to be white people
as well I struggle to categorize their
ideology because it doesn't resemble
anything that I've ever seen as a
coherent philosophy but I do know they
want to cause destruction so we should
continually get you more and more
information but it just doesn't bear any
resemblance to what the communities the
folks who are expressing their grievance
at racism at structural institutional
racism at the problems of policing they
are of and by and for the communities of
New York City and then I think there are
some others whether they're from
different neighborhoods in the city or
from outside the city they have a
different agenda and it is definitely a
violent agenda and it's not consistent
with what community people are calling
for so that's reality but we will get
you more information as we have more
everyone we're going to keep you updated
and we're going to let New Yorkers know
what's happening but most importantly
let's keep the peace today good people
out there speak up
keep the peace in the community and then
we have to move forward we've got a lot
to do in the city we have to get back to
fighting this coronavirus we have to get
back to being unified and doing this
together thank you everyone
to hold on to that hope that's what will
propel us forward and help us heal
there's not a single person here in
Chicago or across the country has not
been affected by what we've been seeing
and reading in the news I had an
exchange this morning with one of the
lawyers for George Floyd was a personal
friend and somebody I know and he said
to me mayor I'm committed to making sure
that we write the wrong not only for mr.
Floyd and his family and that's true but
also for the decades of wrongs that have
been committed I join him in that fight
[Music]
move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away
ok do you know why I'm under arrest sir
why why am i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Kovach 19 condemned ik has resulted in
the worst work of safety crisis in
OSHA's 50-year history nothing compares
yet osha the agency that this nation has
tasked to protect workers have been
largely invisible
[Music]
a standard at this point would be an
unproductive burden for businesses
already struggling to reopen potentially
exposing them to unnecessary liability
risk during an already challenging time
and would do little to advance workplace
safety
[Music]
our Dean said yada yada yada the filly
is my eggs vanilla Garrido
a coach Daniel of Jakarta here Marley
vodka tonic was a
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah personally I get inget oh that
was affordable this is yoga yoga sake we
have no chopper for
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you need chemicals on your skin this
no I person this distant usefulness of
Leopold's klonoa normal Edith am agin de
una normal yachting accesso Aryabhatta
social they laughed as when asked in
normalmente enormous density preemies
women booty show - a conf a cow which
almost BEC does your best on sleepiness
Takuma said to Thole this year given
party rules or to dine out on fasting or
is there well this of tckontis women
[Music]
[Music]
chances are you may have started cooking
more during quarantine which means
you've made plenty of trips to the
grocery store either in person or
virtually but brace yourselves that
chicken wing and hamburger patty it's
about to cost you more money just for
meat processing plants account for about
80% of production in the United States
back in April President Donald Trump
ordered all meat processing plants stay
open they're gonna be very careful they
are as to who's going in to the plant
the quarantine is going to be very
strong even as workers fall ill and
production output suffers so where our
plant operators in all this they have to
go through lower productivity and higher
cost which means they need to make some
major changes and some plants are
already running slower because of social
distancing and fewer workers and some
production lines are fully automated Sen
showed us is a professor at the New
Jersey Institute of Technology he gives
us the numbers he says reducing meat
processing plants to a third of their
capacity and also distributing the
adequate protective equipment this could
all boost chicken prices at grocery
stores by 25 to 30 percent that means if
you buy chicken at 99 cents per pound
for five pounds now at 5.95 Sen
it could cost you up to six dollars and
44 cents for for Texas that means higher
costs for an industry that's been pretty
efficient at putting out cheap protein
getting gas in Caracas is almost
impossible because of a severe food
shortage due to years of mismanagement
lack of investment and corruption in a
country with the largest oil reserves I
try to do it last week but fail I spent
a whole night in a queue of cars in
hopes of pumping gas in the morning only
a few cars are allowed to do it by the
soldiers that control every single gas
station in Caracas people can only pump
gas two days a week according to their
license plate several people in the
light told me they had tried to fill
their tanks for up to four nights
without succeeding how is this possible
in an oil country what's the common
complaint at 5:00 a.m. after spending
the whole night on the street only 20
people were allowed to pump gas at that
point there were over 100 cars there
past 9:00 a.m. I left in disappointment
my cars tank is now empty in the middle
of a quarantine the two coronavirus in
the meantime the friend said may were
way Tomita drivers with dollars were
bribing the officers patrol in the line
the world was that $100 will get you
very close to the front
we move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay do you know why I'm
under arrest sir why why am i under
arrest
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay
do you know why I'm under arrest sir why
why am i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Kovach 19 condemned ik has resulted in
the worst work of safety crisis in
OSHA's 50 year history nothing compares
yet osha
the agency that this nation has tasked
to protect workers have been largely
invisible
[Music]
i standard at this point would be an
unproductive burden for businesses
already struggling to reopen potentially
exposing them to unnecessary liability
risk during an already challenging time
and would do little to advance workplace
safety
[Music]
our Dean said yada yada yada tofu is my
eggs vanilla Garrido a good DNA
lifejacket to you Marilla vodka tonic
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh yeah personally I get inget oh that
was affordable here
Yoga Yoga sake we have no chopper power
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
can we come together - uh no tenemos it
was in Casa initial para que tenemos la
calle
community amenities no I'm saying the
system usefulness of Liat those are
normally a timing in de una noir
normally adding accesso Aryabhatta
social the La Casona skin normal
maintain or restore often said if any
human body show I know says here
Cheyenne if a cow which almost bed could
does your best appearance no Akuma say
well the to truly this year given park
any worse or to dine out on fasting or
is there a little teaser tckontis for
him
[Music]
[Music]
chances are you may have started cooking
more during quarantine which means
you've made plenty of trips to the
grocery store either in person or
virtually but brace yourselves that
chicken wing and hamburger patty it's
about to cost you more money just for
meat processing plants account for about
80% of production in the United States
back in April President Donald Trump
ordered all meat processing plants stay
open they're gonna be very careful they
are as to who's going in to the plant
the quarantine is going to be very
strong even as workers fall ill and
production output suffers so where our
plant operators in all this they have to
go through lower productivity and higher
costs which means they need to make some
major changes and some plants are
already running slower because of social
distancing and fewer workers and some
production lines are fully automated
tensho does is a professor at the New
Jersey Institute of Technology he gives
us the numbers he says reducing meat
processing plants to a third of their
capacity and also distributing the
adequate protective equipment this could
all boost chicken prices at grocery
stores by 25 to 30 percent that means if
you buy chicken at 99 cents per pound
for five pounds now at 5.5 cents
it could cost you up to six dollars and
44 cents before taxes that means higher
costs for an industry that's been pretty
efficient at putting out cheap protein
getting gas in Caracas is almost
impossible because of a severe food
shortage to the years of mismanagement
lack of investment and corruption in a
country with the largest oil reserve I
try to do it last week but fail I spent
a whole night in a queue of cars in
hopes of pumping gas in the morning only
a few cars are allowed to do it by the
soldiers that control every single gas
station in Caracas people can only pump
gas two days a week according to their
license plate several people in the
light told me they had tried to fill
their tanks for up to four nights
without succeeding how is this possible
in an oil country what's the common
complaint at 5 a.m. after spending the
whole night on the street only 20 people
were allowed to pump gas at that point
there were over 100 cars there past 9:00
a.m. I left in this appointment my cars
tank is now empty in the middle of a
quarantine due to coronavirus in the
meantime the friend said may were
waiting Tomita drivers with dollars were
bribing the officers patrolling the land
the world was that $100 will get you
very close to the front
we move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay do you I am under
arrest sir why am i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
move back to where you'd like here we
are live on the air at the moment and
scattering the protesters at that point
for people to clear the area and so we
walked away okay do you know why I'm
under arrest sir why am i under arrest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]